[Musique]
bonjour à tous je crois qu'on peut vivre
des rapports humains qui sont d'assez
sur le coeur c'est même essentiel est
que le business et les pires sont pas
incompatibles au contraire lamouri
d'autres et c'est ce que je vais essayer
de vous expliquer les tissages de
charlie en quelques mots avant qu'on ait
70 personnes c'est une entreprise qui
loue depuis très longtemps j'ai reprise
il ya 20 ans depuis quelques années les
l'objectif clairement affirmée et on
arrivera à un autre but
le jour où chaque personne de cette
entreprise pourra vraiment s'épanouir
pensa dans sa plénitude d'êtres humains
dansant dans son intégrité d'êtres
humains évidemment c'est un long chemin
et on a je crois pas retrouvé quelques
étapes
évidemment pour beaucoup à faire un
atteindra jamais ce but mais en quelques
mots j'ai pris conscience des quelques
années que l'enlisement des débats en se
renseignant à droite à gauche et
notamment un sondage qui répondent à ce
qui a été fait en 2009 sondage gallup
qui m'a vraiment marqué son d'acheter
sur 430 mes salariés dans 30 pays bande
monde qui classait les salariés en trois
catégories ceux qui sont activement
engagés en phase avec la stratégie de
l'entreprise les salariés qui sont
activement des engagés qui vont à
l'encontre de la stratégie d'entreprise
ceux qui sont entre les deux qui
viennent là parce qu'ils ont un salaire
à la fin du mans en france quand ce
sondage il y avait
7 % de salariés activement engagés et 9
% et 27 % de salariés activement des
engagements on comprend bien que dans
une entreprise
si les gens viennent bosser avec la
banane le matin ils vont être plus
efficaces que s'ils viennent bosser avec
la boule autres comment mettre en oeuvre
tout ça et comment trouver un système de
fonctionnement qui permet de révéler
cette extraordinaire potentiel qu'il ya
dans chaque personne est-ce que c'est
pas le but de l'entreprise
est ce que finalement si on y arrive
dans l'entreprise de l' entreprise va
pas mieux marché que les autres donc
finalement sa réussite économique n'est
qu'une conséquence du fait que les
hommes comme disait je pense pas ce
culte à l'heure un poussin est
supérieure à 2 évidemment sur les
cinquante ou soixante dix
si on arrive à mettre en résonance le
potentiel a révélé des potentiels de
chacun et que chacun pousse vraiment
mettre son potentiel au service du bien
commun constitue cette offre propre
collectivité l'entreprise la
mondialisation ne nous font ne nous fait
pas peur
rien ne nous fait peur parce que parce
qu'on serait une entreprise
théoriquement une capacité tout à fait
exceptionnel dans le cadre de cette
recherche géré assez naturellement on a
on avait des joueuses qui étaient en
place ce qui était un petit peu comme ça
je vais vous parler du concept de
l'entreprise libéré c'est à dire dans
notre entreprise nous avions d'abord 15
personnes à la création et sur ces 15
personnes y en a 12 ans télétravail
il ya peut-être boss de chez elle à
paris à lyon ou ailleurs
elles n'ont aucun contrôle aucun
objectif elles organisent leur temps
absolument comme elles veulent et
vraiment je pense qu'on a une équipe de
création qui est parmi les plus
performantes de démarche est sans doute
grâce à ça
dans l'entreprise on est des acras
entreprises sont connaissez peut-être
une ou deux là même qui s'appelle
l'étole qui n'utilisent commence à être
un petit peu connu donc c'est une jeune
femme qui est des techniciennes d'armure
âge c'est à dire qu'elle faisait sur
l'ordinateur des croisements de films et
un jour elle a eu l'idée de créer un
marques au sein de l'entreprise qui
s'appelle des tonnes qui sont des et
holt sont faites en coton biologique qui
sont infectés adsl village chez de vaud
qui sont évidemment conçu et édité chez
nous qui sont confectionnés
chez nous on a monté une ligue des
conceptions elle a maintenu des
prospections et qui sont lavés et walsh
était scellé ou savane marseille même le
même le savon et français aucunes
connaissances commerciales
elle ne parle pas français elle ne
plaira parle pas anglais et le stress
commence à faire ses effets ou en train
de partir au sénat et donc sophie
aujourd'hui elle a embauché sept
personnes élevant ses étapes dans 23
pays
450 boutiques et les faits et 8% du
chiffre d'affaires de l'entreprise
donc ça c'est c'est l'expression de ce
potentiel extraordinaire que chaque
personne et il est bon qu'il ya deux
autres intra-entreprise qui se sont
créés tout ça pour vous expliquer ce
processus mais à mon avis est très
important dans les entreprises et
l'entreprise libéré qu'est ce que c'est
libéré ça veut pas dire entreprise qui
fait chacun fait ce qu'il veut c'est une
entreprise où on a enlevé le couvercle
est justement sur ce potentiel que
chaque être humain et ça quand on peut
le faire
l'homme pour être motivés il a besoin de
quelques points essentiels on a déjà
parlé au cours de cette journée
premièrement il a besoin d'être autonome
il a besoin d'être libre de son action
on l'a illustré autres adam
l'intrapreneuriat des créatrices
deuxième point à son il a besoin de se
sentir reconnus tu as besoin de se
sentir utile
il a besoin d'avoir bus un sens à ce
qu'il fait il a envie quand ils se
lèvent le matin de se dire ça vaut la
peine de se lever et il faut qu'ils
aient du plaisir à construire à coopérer
à travailler avec une équipe bien faire
de financement si on a tout ça on peut
avoir vraiment une énergie
extraordinaire tout ce qui se met en
oeuvre dans l'entreprise et au sein de
chaque personne y est ce que c'est pas
ça finalement le le rôle de biens de
l'entreprise de mettre en oeuvre ce
potentiel et l'entreprise libérer pour
vous expliquer ce que c'est c'est très
simple vous avez deux grands types
d'organisation vous avez les entreprises
pourquoi les entreprises comment les
entreprises commencent des entreprises
où le chef de cadres c'est ce qu'il faut
faire il va écrire un process et
l'opérateur nous applique le process
l'opérateur il n'est pas intelligent qui
doit habiter de process quand je
d'opérateurs ceni s'est pas
nécessairement
un ouvrier mais ça doit être des tâches
refusé d'abord est effectivement une
opération a notamment toutes les
opérations finalement il ya dans toutes
les opérations de propre et donc le
cadre où le patron donne à l'opérateur
en process l'opérateur applique le
procès ce point mort il n'a pas de il
n'a pas d'autonomie et si jamais il ya
un dysfonctionnement créé une procédure
l'archétype de ça c'est une candide je
suis à dinan tel bureau de la fonction
publique
j'ai posé une question les
fonctionnaires sont complètement
psychorigide du système
évidemment pas le fonctionnaire
psychorigide ces systèmes dans le daily
mail parce qu'effectivement la question
oppose la personne elle ne rentre pas
dans le cadre des centaines de
procédures souvent contradictoires qui
régissent sa vie à ce lieu fonctionnel
et donc il ne peut pas y répondre a
répondu psychorigide
de l'autre côté on a des entreprises
pourquoi l'entreprise pourquoi on part
du principe que l'opérateur à partir du
moment où il s'est désormais évidemment
global est censé savoir faire le boulot
il donc on va lui demander d'atteindre
le pourquoi
charge à lui de mettre en oeuvre son
intelligence mais modèle intellectuel la
déco amercian comptables financières etc
c'est ici la nuit de mettre en oeuvre
cet état cité c'est adam son potentiel
donc cette entreprise pourquoi elle est
basée sur l'autonomie des opérateurs
elle est basée sur des contrôles qui
sont de plus mais plus léger possible
est sûre ni harrachis qui est la plus
plate possible contrairement au système
comand au contraire la hiérarchie est
très importante puisque c'est d'ailleurs
un flic il faut faire avec le monde
politique
jean dominique senard on a la chance à
roanne d'avoir lieu
l'usiné michelin de roanne et première
usine je crois que chaque les parties
grâce aux systèmes d'entreprise
responsabilisante vous avez ça
responsabilise ans chez eux
dominique saint dominique senard le
patron de michelin a écrit dans les
échos qu'une considère ce système de
management comme l'avenir de l'industrie
européenne qui aura plus d'industries
ici s'il est si les gens ne mettent pas
en place des systèmes de management qui
personnifie permettent de motiver les
équipes de leur donner l'autonomie est
de permette aux gens d'être d'être
vraiment acteurs de leur job et
contributeur au bien commun que
constitue une entreprise ça c'est
vraiment avant un sujet majeur
et finalement on pourrait se dire est ce
que dans notre civilisation est ce que
dans notre société on s'est pas trompé
de finalité elle a inventé l'argent il
ya dix mille ans avant c'était le troc
un très pratique le trompe donc l'argent
est un but extraordinaire qui permet de
fluidifier les échanges et qui est
vraiment à changer la vie de l'humanité
mais c'était un outil pour une finalité
et puis après au début du 19e siècle
on a inventé l'entreprise l'entreprise
c'est un extraordinaire outil qui permet
de produire plus de 15 service qui
permet de faciliter la vie des gens
c'est un extraordinaire outil qui permet
de faciliter
c'est à midi c'est devenu une finalité
est ce que finalement on va se dire que
la seule finalité c'est l'homme
la seule finalité qui vaut la peine
c'est
comment est ce qu'on va faire pour pour
faire grandir l'homme pour apporter
quelque chose à l'autre on a parlé de
sens à plusieurs reprises est ce que le
sens seul sens qui vaut la peine
la seule chose qui venant se lever et
maintenant c'est de se dire qu'est ce
que je vais apporter
donc cette réflexion sur l'entreprise
responsabilisante libéré sur les modèles
de management que nous sommes en train
de mettre en place dans l'embarras de
l'entreprise est-ce que c'est pas
quelque chose sur lesquels il faut qu'on
se pose une question en faut qu'on se
pose des questions sur sur la manière
dont on veut faire évoluer notre société
est ce que finalement la
financiarisation de notre de notre
société volstagg offensivement on
imagine qu'ils aient un système qui
parce qu'on à 8% de rendement de
résultat net
le dit pour cent on supprime
instantanément dix mille en emploi d'un
trait de plume
est ce que c'est bien simple finalement
on y assiste au sommet de 12 95% des
jambes
18% des gens avec qui on en parle trouve
ça trouve ça affligeant mais finalement
rien ne change
le changement il va devenir plus bas d
avenir de nous je pense que dans dans
chacun de nos métiers dans chacune de
nos entreprises on peut se dire qu'on
peut arriver à modifier les choses et
nous y la france est un pays qui est en
avance sur ce système les entreprises
libéré est un pays qui va plus vite que
les autres sans doute
parce que l'on est un système de la
france a un système très contraint
beaucoup de normes d'administration un
peu tentaculaire certains disent que
c'est le seul qui soviétique qui a
réussi espérons cette contrainte cette
organisation autour comme nous puissent
pas aller vers des systèmes qui soit
différent est-ce qu'on n'a pas aussi
financiarisé nos relations vous même
est-ce qu'on n'est pas dans un système
de plus en plus je ne vais faire quelque
chose que si j'ai un intérêt si ça va me
rapporter que notre quotidien de ne
fonctionne opération est ce que
finalement l'entreprise c'est pas un
extraordinaire outil support de de
relations vu même extrêmement forte de
nous donner la définition bouddhisme du
travail que je trouve vachement
vachement intéressante
le travail c'est d'abord l'endroit où on
peut mettre en oeuvre ses talents c'est
aussi l'endroit où il faut détecter
c'est pas simple de retrouver ce détail
et les mettre au service de cette
collectivité
le deuxième point c'est que le travail
c'est un endroit où on travaille en
équipe généralement travail en équipe ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire être capable
donc françoise me l'a expliqué très
largement tout à l'heure le travail en
équipe
donc travailler en équipe ce avec les
écoutait le point de vue de l'autre ça
veut dire donner le sien parce que si on
donne patients participant au travail de
l'été évidemment il faut donner le sien
et que finalement la bonne décision ça
va être la synthèse de ce que pense aux
autres ce qu'on pense nous donc
finalement on a oublié un petit peu son
ego donc on a grandi en humanité donc on
a grandi il est le troisième prince et
sorman c'est évidemment quelque chose
un endroit qui nous permettent d'avoir
une rémunération et de vivre de notre
travail
mais vivre de notre travail c'est
évidemment essentiel c'est nos besoins
primaires fondamentaux mais tous les
autres on n'est pas qu'un estomac mais
aussi un câlin en sable il y en a 2 29%
et on a comparé la évidemment beaugrand
de nombre d'heures en ont fait le
travail et ces terrains si on a si
l'entreprise est un support yamashita tu
laisses le plus possible je ne crois pas
que c'est en ces termes là niveau qu'il
faut raisonner investir si vraiment les
gens vont pouvoir se réaliser dans leur
plénitude à leur intégrité d'êtres
humains vraiment y'a pas de problème des
membres de sa terrasse libre le vrai
problème c'est si on crée un système il
n'y a pas de sens les gens n'ont pas de
sens
mais ce sont deux parties ne se sont pas
utiles les relations sont venus sont
difficiles c'est un environnement qui
est toxique
là effectivement il faut qu'il y ait un
nombre d'heures le plus faible possible
pour éviter cette toxicité
laissez-passer pas là d'un sujet le
sujet se dire comment est ce qu'on peut
faire pour que cette première ne m'en
sois le plus propice possible à
l'épanouissement même c'est vraiment
c'est vraiment le rôle de l'entreprise
et je crois que en aucun cas céder
réglementation c'est senna balle en jeu
une codification de normes qu'on nous
explique comment il faut qu'on fasse
évidemment le la manière pour nous
entreprises on vit la tentaculaire
tentaculaire système public en français
de revenir si évidemment un système
commandes c'est-à-dire qu'on nous
explique comment fait on doit faire
évidemment que le fonctionnaire de
voxels il a aucune idée comment marche
midem textile à chaque nuit évidemment
donc autant nous devons libérer le
potentiel de de nos collaborateurs au
même titre je pense que c'est c'est pas
du tout politique ce que je lui dis non
c'est vraiment un ressenti très très
profonde de la manière dont fonctionne
l'être humain que d'êtres humains il a
besoin d'autonomie
il a besoin d'être libre de son
fonctionnement de ses actions pour
donner de son son potentiel et tous ses
talents et est ce que finalement ce but
c'est pas c'est pas ça le sujet et faire
que l'homme que chacun puisse se mettre
en oeuvre ses talents au service bien
commun une ce bien commun c'est à dire
l'entreprise
elle doit elle apporter un service aux
autres ça s'appelle le bien - la portée
nationale
[Applaudissements]